In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinoxadeon for September 2, on which we commemorate our Holy Father
John the Faster, patriarch of Constantinople.
Saint John the Faster was born and brought up in Constantinople in the reign of the Emperor
Justin II, in the years 565 through 578.
He worked as an engraver at the mint, and from his youth lived in righteousness with fervent
love for God.
On several occasions he received prophetic revelations of the high office the Lord had
in store for him.
His virtuous reputation came to the notice of the patriarch John II's schulasticals, who
ordained him deacon of the clergy of Constantinople, and gave him charge over the distribution
of alms, taking the merciful Christ as his pattern, John brought true charity to this task.
He gave freely and even handedly to all whether worthy or unworthy, and the more he distributed
the more God filled his purse so that it seemed inexhaustible.
On the death of the patriarch Utakis, in April in the year 582, John reluctantly accepted
the succession, but throughout the 13 years of his patriarchate, he persevered in his
austere manner of life, for which he became known as the Faster.
It is said that he went for almost six months without drinking water.
His food consisted only of lettuce and some melon, and a few grapes or figs.
He did not lie down to sleep, but sat with his legs against his chest.
When he overslept the short time he allotted for repose, he would keep vigil throughout the
following night to subdue his body and prepare it for the vigil without end of the sons of
the resurrection.
His love for the poor was so great that he expended all his funds in alms, and he had to ask
the emperor for a loan to carry on his works of charity.
On his death, in the year 595, the emperor attempted to recover the debt, but the patriarch
of the Queen of Cities was found to own nothing but an old woolen cloak and a thin blanket.
St. John worked many miracles in the course of his life.
He healed a man-born blind in giving him the Holy Communion, calmed a tempest by his prayer.
Drove away the barbarians that were about to attack the city and healed many barren women.
For his spiritual flock, he was not simply the good shepherd, mediator and high priest,
but the living image of divine providence, which is poured forth abundantly on the righteous
and on sinners alike.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's, O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.